joe biden's son hunter is emerging as an
issue in the presidential campaign
we're learning new information tonight
about a senate republican investigation
into the younger biden chief
congressional correspondent mike emanuel
has details
the 87-page report says in 2015 two
senior state department officials george
kent
and amos hochstein raised concerns to
vice president joe biden's office and
even with biden personally
about the perception of a conflict of
interest regarding hunter biden's role
on burisma's board
despite the efforts of these individuals
their concerns appear to have fallen
on deaf ears and warning of the risk of
undermining u.s policy in ukraine
quote officials within the obama
administration ignored the glaring
warning
signs when the vice president's son
joined the board of a company
owned by a corrupt ukrainian oligarch
senate republican chairman ron johnson
and chuck grassley led the report and no
treasury records show potential
criminal activity relating to
transactions among and between
among and between hunter biden his
family his associates and foreign
nationals
a key senate republican calls the
findings extremely troubling
there's been a lot done a lot interviews
there's a lot to
see there and this is this is very
serious
a spokesman for the biden campaign says
this is all about the election
quote an attack founded on a long
disproven hard core right wing
conspiracy theory that hinges on senator
johnson himself being corrupt
and that the senator has now explicitly
stated he's attempting to exploit to
bail out donald trump's reelection
campaign
the senate democratic leader blasted
this probe senators
grassley and johnson should reimburse
taxpayers
for the money they wasted the johnson
report should be relegated
to the dust spin of history senator tom
cotton says there's no reason to believe
these practices would change
if joe biden's in the white house for
decades
hunter biden and joe biden's brother
have been coasting
off of his public office earning
millions of dollars from
chinese firms and ukrainian oligarchs in
a statement the trump campaign says this
report is further evidence that if joe
biden wins
china and many other foreign interests
with a financial stake in the biden
family
win too